Today is the day!
Our field trip to the stingray migration.
Stingray Migration.
Migration is about going home...
Home.
...which is where you're from.
How do the stingrays all know where to go?
Instinct,...
...something deep inside you that feels so familiar that you have to listen to it.
My mom, my dad, I have a family.
We will never forget you, Dory.
What if I forget you?
I miss them.
You know what that feels like?
Yes.
Then we better get going!
Totally sick.
Isn't it great?
No!
I'm gonna be totally sick.
Can you help me...
Sorry, not a great swimmer.
I think you swam beautifully.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Wait.
Dory?
Yes?
Dory!
Yes.
You and I were friends!
No.
It was so much fun 'cause I'd tell you a story...
...and then you'd completely forget about it...
...and then I get to tell it to you over and over again.